- "Saturday Night Live" has
so many New York moments
that it's been crazy for
me to even think about,
but probably one of my
biggest and most fond memories
was the SNL 40th Anniversary Party.
The after parties are always fun,
but this after party was
the 40th anniversary,
and everyone who was anyone,
it was just crazy amount
of people were there.
And as soon as I walked in,
Paul McCartney was calling
my name to go onstage.
And he was there with Dan
Aykroyd and Jim Belushi.
And I got on stage and Dan Aykroyd said,
"Kid (claps) I've done this
for 40 years, it's your turn.
You gotta rock this party."
And so there was no band, it was just me,
and Paul McCartney, and Dan, we did one,
and we just had people
come up from the crowd
and play and jam out and play songs.
And the end of the night,
we're on stage singing
with Bill Murray and
Chris Rock and Chappelle,
and Dave Chappelle goes to me,
"Jimmy, if you ask
nicely, I think he's here,
but if you ask, you could
probably get Prince to come up."
- What?
- And so at the end of the night,
I just go,
and it was just like probably
two, three in the morning.
I go, "Prince, if you're there,
I'd love to have you
come up and sing a song."
And all of a sudden, the crowd parted,
and this purple smoke, I swear,
it's like true.
(Kelly laughs)
It's almost like his legs
were not touching the ground.
His legs were just kind of floating.
And he was floating across the room,
(Kelly clapping)
and I go, oh my goodness.
And he comes up, and he
peels off these gloves,
and he hands me his gloves.
And I hand him a guitar.
And not only does he play,
he plays, "Let's Go Crazy".
- Oh my gosh.
I really wish in that moment
you would have like, right
when he entered the stage,
peeled off the gloves,
you would have just looked and been like,
"A bit dramatic, but okay." (laughs)
(audience and Jimmy laughing)
'Cause that would've
been everything. (laughs)
- I guess we're gonna do this.
We rocked the house, it crushed!
It was epic!
- That's so cool, too.
And, I don't know, I've
sang a bunch on "SNL",
but I've never like hosted it.
And I don't know if I will now,
'cause I was in New York
when Blake Shelton hosted it,
and it's so much time that
y'all all spend together.
I mean, y'all are like
family, (claps) like nonstop.
So I can imagine at that kinda party
where you've got everybody there
and you're celebrating
all these friendships
that are like deep friendships,
y'all are around each other all the time.
- You live with each other,
basically, at "Saturday Night Live".
I mean, we were kind of,
it's like a dorm room.
It's like Horatio Sanz
and I were office mates,
and we had blankets there,
we would stay up all
night trying to write.
And I remember Dan Aykroyd
coming in just to say,
"Hi, you're the new guys.
Just wanna say hello to you guys."
And we're like, freaking out.
It was Dan Aykroyd, like, "Oh my gosh."
He's like, "Do you want me to show you
where me and John used to go?"
And I go, "Okay."
And he goes, "You know,
we had all the keys to
all these rooms in 'SNL',"
and he brought me and Horatio
into someone's office,
snuck through their window, and
we're out on the 11th floor.
And there's like grass up
there, and like a coy pond.
It's the weirdest spot.
- What?
- And him and John used
to go up there, and right.
- Yeah, they're doing
(audience and Jimmy laughing)
what do they call it?
What did we call that on tour?
A safety meeting.
That's what everybody would say,
"Oh, they're at a safety meeting."
I was like, "Okay."